this is the first day of your new life what
happened yesterday doesn’t matter
what you were before no one
cares
now what matters is who you will be today
what you know and what you are capable of
questions may remain unanswered but
how can you sleep peacefully later
to know you to know the limits of your
capabilities
from the line of the border you are ready to break yourself to
exhaustion every day here my
hardens with fat and everyday life it is you who
decided to prove something to yourself the commander
here only so that you can
see the enemy in him because without an enemy
this is not a battle  and without a fight there is no victory,
in fact, the main enemy is you
yesterday and
your task is to hunt down the enemy to catch up with him
to surpass him to become a better winner than he is
because tomorrow is the first day of your
new life